I want to begin it's a somewhat somber
note a member of the cast who couldn't
be here today it's been a number of
years they haven't been kind to her and
she couldn't make the trip but the alien
queen she's seen better days Jim and
Gail this was a character and I can't
help but think of her as a character and
not an effect or a creature this is the
alien queen is a character you didn't
know you could pull off when you dreamed
it up and you and even before you wrote
the character this final scene in this
Throwdown between Ripley and this big
momma
big space mama you you had to do a test
let's talk about the test you did with
the late Stan Winston just approved
yourselves let's hear it for Stan
Winston Stan was a great friend and
collaborator and I'm sure he would have
loved to have been here as well and and
he had such a big he was part of the
cast essentially because he created the
the alien queen made her live and
breathe although I always say that we
believe the alien queen was real because
Sigourney made us believe that Ripley
was seeing it it wasn't real now you
tell me she wouldn't look I mean cuz
there were hydraulics and mechanics and
guys inside it and all kinds of crazy
tricks guy with a fishing line on a pole
to move the tail around and Sigourney
didn't want to know about any of that
stuff because she wanted it to be real
in her mind you know it was rubber right
it was rubber and fiberglass she is out
roaming around this world hungry and
angry and you should all be careful
she's pissed off I bet she is
so Gail you I think you were telling me
when we did our story that you know the
truth is back then you didn't have CGI
to save your ass if you didn't get it
right on set
and and that made us really honest so
part of that honesty is making sure to
vet
what you were planning to show on screen
way in the early stages and Jim and Stan
Winston and was it Shane may have got
together in the parking lot of Stan
Winston studios with black garbage bags
and ski poles and Jim directed yeah we
made the first version of the alien
queen well I had a I had an idea for
that what the Queen would look like but
then the question you know I had to sit
down with Stan say how are we gonna make
this thing real physically move and it
was too spindly for animatronics so we
figured well we'll just make it really
light little puppet it and guys will
move the arms so there's actually two
guys inside it and then there's a but I
think 14 operators off-camera that are
moving the head around and the jaws and
all that which is pretty common it was
done in Jurassic Park and that sort of
thing afterwards but we did this very
lightweight model so that we could see
if it had the right the right feeling
the right silhouette anyway that's it
why what and you did it out in the
parking lot yeah why because you needed
the space but yeah they got all she's
big she's 14 feet tall she's probably 20
feet across the arms man let's talk to
the actors guy we will talk about the
visual effects oh that was probably when
we started the film in late August or
early September September I think and
this would have been in May in June
before we moved to England yeah we shot
the whole thing at Pinewood student
reparation preparation no Sigourney you
got an Oscar nomination for this part
for playing for aliens but I mean
everybody knows what a real-life badass
you are so how much acting was going on
with Ripley how much of Ripley is you
and vice-versa
well I just told Gale who produces the
walking dead that in spite of what I
played I do not have the courage to look
at even five minutes of it because I'm
so suggest
to goal that I will now then I would see
zombies everywhere on the New York
streets or in the woods or whatever so
I'm it was I realize now all acting I
actually based it on a friend of mine
who's an environmentalist who's kind of
it's not that she's not kind and has
feelings but she's very kind of
unsentimental about things she just goes
forward and gets things done so she was
my inspiration as well as the incredible
writing and and the incredible
situations that Jim put me in with with
Newt and with these guys who all thought
I was a kind of loser and bad luck and
you know for in real life but uh no I
mean that's what you get as an actor you
you come to the set and you know with
the this ensemble when they you know
when the scenes happened it was all so
real and I could feel they're just kind
of like who is this woman that we're
stuck with and we're gonna have to save
you all know what happened so I just
want to start with with bill I'd like to
thank the Academy I just have three
words to say game over man
how did Hudson ever get through like
basic training man nerves of steel you
know he's not a coward I I don't run I
mean Paul Reiser no he's the coward he
tries it one way to sneak out the back
door he does the classic kind of but uh
what does that scene conjure in your
mind what memories does that evoke you
know I your favorite said your favorite
said the ABC tried to kill you all the
whole ceiling collapsed I thought God
iris really be sucking here ya know you
know I have to say when I played this
character I got with Jill when I got the
call to do this I I was so thrilled but
I was at the same time very nervous and
it's it's hard to sustain the guy that's
always scared I should have you know in
retrospect 30 years later I'm looking
you know it's okay but I didn't embrace
it like I should have I was very nervous
Sigourney was so supportive but I were
brilliant I thought the character was
just gonna wear out as welcome and
people are just gonna win is this guy
gonna die already
you know Jim used the Hudson character
and me in the role as it's kind of a I
guess kind of a pressure release valve
it's exactly what it was that it's the
measure of the tension of the film on
the audience that that and you give them
the ability to laugh and it releases
that tension so that so that it can
build up again I just wish I could have
laughed more and then you gave him a
heroic ending saving us that's right
it's actually the one one of the few
things that's not in the script as the
the way we did it is that you go down
fighting and you made up your own
dialogue on that the thing is that bill
made up differ
dialogue on every take and he was
yelling it over a machine gun so none of
it actually recorded and we spent about
four hours in ADR one day trying to
figure out what he said still no no Jim
we're still not 100 should we remove it
oh yeah you want some of this take that
come here
it just was random now is it true that
Lance the scene with a knife over Bill's
hand that that was very well rehearsed
except with bill that you were not
involved in the rehearsal for that is
that story true that's one of the
legends well there's a lot of legends
and they're all true of course I'll tell
you the way it happened all right
bill it works bill being the kind of
actor he is he he jumped right in on it
I mean Jim and I were sitting to the
side and I said Jim what if I put my
hand on Bill's hand I'll protect him
that's my nature you know so and I'll do
the thing as quick and as hard as I can
and bill jump right in on it so I mean
he played it like and made it work I
mean it was I just didn't want to do a
demonstration that's what I felt
yeah you wanted to protect somebody that
well yeah I wanted to cut his pinkie
Lansford Lance works very internally on
the character and for a long time and so
he was really fast with the knife gag
but on the day he came up with the
suggestion so he did it the thing that's
interesting is that I wasn't sure if it
was fast enough to look superhuman and
so we under cranked the camera on some
of the takes we wound up not using it
because it was too fast it takes it's in
the movie is actually Lance doing it
that fast
grab his hand right now and just Michael
you know the I think it's fair to say
he's a strong silent type in that scene
he's contemplating he doesn't say a lot
he's very stoic and you came you were
one of the last people to join the cast
I believe that's the story I heard that
you came on kind of at the last minute
what was it like joining this group sort
of already in motion and and how did you
get inside the head of Hick's well first
of all I had some comfort level because
I had worked with Jim and Gail on the
Terminator and I'm glad I glad I did a
good job for him on that one yeah I got
a call from Gail on a Friday night I was
in Studio City and she called me Gail
are you doing she said is your passport
in order and I said yeah I think so and
she said can you be here Monday morning
to play Hicks and I said hell yes so I
got to jump right into it and Hicks is
not a guy that you know talks a lot so
there wasn't a lot of there was a
feeling and there's always been a
feeling about this cast that we all
supported each other and you don't
always get that on films that you work
with I've never never heard anybody on
this set or the other actors work say
anything negative about anybody else on
us on the set as far as actors though
and and actresses go and and believe me
that stuff happens all
time and I you know I credit Sigourney
really because you know Sigourney's
beautiful she is sexy she is a brilliant
actress she is smart she's got a great
sense of humor but I think one of the
reasons the gym and Gale liked her so
much as she has a incredible work ethic
nobody works harder than maybe Jim but
hardly anybody in Gale the hardly
anybody works as hard as she does
and the cast made me feel welcome right
from the very beginning and if you you
notice Hicks doesn't have a lot of
dialogue but you know so it wasn't like
hard learning lines and so on and so
forth the cast just they just embraced
me and again I you know Sigourney was
kind of the head of the snake when it
came to us and and and you know I just I
just felt like I was part of the team
from the moment that I showed up I think
everybody wanted me to do well and I you
know one I saw the movie about ten
months ago I think a year ago whatever
and I was watching television and I was
flipping through the channels and the
part that I started watching was when
they solder that thing open or with a
fire and the thing falls through and I
thought okay here we are at the
beginning of the movie and
you know and I watched it and there was
no commercials and you know of course I
said I hadn't seen in about 10 years
and I watched it and it was you know so
fun to watch and what I really had kind
of forgotten about but not really was
the relationship that Hicks has with
Ripley you know and the fact that I've
always wanted to support leading ladies
as an actor I've always wanted to say
well if you're more comfortable here
than I can stand over here and it's
always been very important to me to
support my my leading lady but Jim
actually wrote that into the script and
I don't get a chance to play that kind
of leading man thing so often you know
I'm usually crazy you know wild whatever
and when I saw the movie this last time
I thought what a what a nice
relationship we had it was just such a
and again it was written that way there
was no improvisation Jim knew exactly
what he was doing I think it could have
gone somewhere a Fincher had killed you
all shots fired I think you're right no
one could have played that part as like
you did you just so effortless and so
warm and so kind of debonair even though
you were a grunt
I want to ask Paul Reiser now Paul
you're so fun to hate in this movie how
did you find Burke who is he based on
well you know before I before Jim
actually cast me they had two big black
bags and they would hold up and see if
they can make it look like me and it
didn't work it did not work and they
said we're gonna have to go with the guy
what was the question that's all I had
hurt you but yeah I've always said this
this is one of those rare scripts that
you read and it's not only you know it's
good it's gonna be a hit but it's just
like it was compelling too as a as a
read just physically reading it it was
it was gripping and and I looked I said
well if this guy's crazy enough to let
me be in his movie then I thought well I
just have I have this part this movie is
gonna be great I have this much and my
task was a very as an actor my choice
was don't screw the whole movie up and
that was my thing if I can just not stop
the film when people go wait a second
why is this guy in the movie then I'm
okay so luckily it worked
I think I could be wrong a lot of people
did walk out I think what do you did it
work guys we don't know well you say a
bad guy I send misunderstood you think
it's good some just misunderstood I
didn't say good misunderstood what was
it like in the cast dynamic though
because as the guy who none of the other
characters liked did any of that bleed
over to where you a method actor did you
manage to alienate the whole cast at any
point well I'm sure she kept the you
know what I was actually everybody it
was who everybody was very supportive we
all hung out but what was really um kind
of excused upon alienating was these
guys had like two or three weeks of boot
camp and they had all their all the
equipment and I had I came I was not in
that and I had like a little little
notebook and a pencil that was it
I said I want all the cool stuff that
they have I remember that was a choice I
said I'm bring this little Filofax and
the day before I fresh Jim
said think seriously if you want to have
that prop because you're going to hold
that for the next three months maybe
Burke loses it in the bathroom or
something we can change our mind
midcourse well yes that was the only
part I felt like I want to be with those
guys with all the gear mm-hmm did you
wish you had done the boot camp or were
you fit enough you know what when you're
fit enough you don't even have to have
it and that's they said you know what
you're fine as is you got to wear the
suit with a funny collar yes the suit
there was a we had about 12 meetings on
a suit in the beginning and the
beginning of the film I wear a suit and
usually get measured you they measure
your waist and your shoulders and you're
done this was like literally 72
different measurements from your eye to
your spleen they measured everything and
I get I can make em this is gonna be
some phenomenal suit I can't wait to see
what they've done with these measurement
and I get there's a regular suit with
that Wow they spared no expense with
this suit apparently but that was that
was cool I did get a cool yeah costumes
than anything else it was like they they
had to focus on something and they
couldn't quite tell Jim you know and the
special effects or anything else so they
focused on I mean the number of
conversations I had about your wardrobe
which you've never knew until now was
unbelievable Jim knows I mean we
basically you know said if you really
don't like something it's gonna be two
weeks to reshoot it and that's gonna be
you know eight million dollars what do
you think they're like we like it I'm so
happy to see Carrie hen here and I think
you didn't acting did not become your
profession teaching did but I wondered
what's it like you're you teach fourth
grade so I'm guessing they're too young
to see you in aliens but do the kids all
know that but there are some times when
my students will come and they'll say oh
my parents let me watch aliens this
weekend and I think but so many of them
like their parents
they'll come to me like around
Christmastime usually around their dad's
birthday and they'll like pull the DVD
out of their backpack and it okay after
school just quietly come over you know I
was gonna say I bet you like
parent-teacher conferences are always
like somebody's hauling along their
blu-ray well no but I have had a couple
kids that said my dad has never gone to
a conference before it's always just my
mom but they both came I think it's
because of you so you were telling me a
little bit earlier today that you were
just you weren't like your parents
weren't trying to get you into acting
like how did you get discovered by Jim
and Gail um it was kind of one of those
freak things that just happened my dad
was in the Air Force and he was
stationed overseas in England and I was
eating lunch in the school cafeteria and
I never I usually went home for lunch
but it happened to be a day that my mom
wasn't going to be home so I happened to
be eating that day which is now looking
back fate and someone took my picture
and nowadays people would think it was
creepy back then I didn't even think
about it like I didn't even go home and
say anything to my parents about someone
taking my picture and so a couple days
later my dad he worked in the hospital
and so the school nurse called him and
said you know someone took Kerry's
picture and they're looking for someone
to be in a movie just to give you a
heads up and my dad said came home did
someone take your picture and I said
yeah um it was Sarah Jackson she won't
she worked for Mary's fairies always
yeah there was a creepy guy and it just
pumped out yeah and then I went back and
did a lot of auditions at the school and
then I know one time he they had us all
go down on a bus like a bunch of us from
our school and then it just kind of
happened and one day they called up I
think it was Gail I'm not sure called up
and asked that they wanted me to meet
Sigourney which of course at the time I
was like oh my gosh ghostbusters this is
so amazing
um and so I went it we went there and
went in and it was I mean I think
immediately like I just felt an
immediate bond and then a few days later
they called up and said that I had the
part it I had no clue really what I was
doing
ya never heard that story like I've
never heard about somebody who has no
training and no real desire to be in a
movie being in a movie Jim what did you
see what were you looking for and what
did you see and carry then I saw what
you see in the film you know and we we
had seen a lot of young actors a lot of
them you know we're doing commercials
and things like that and they would
always smile at the end of every line
you know and I wanted somebody that
hadn't been sort of conditioned by the
system and you know contaminated by the
system really and Carrie just brought
this incredible realness to it you know
and of course because she wasn't an
experienced actor and she was working on
a [ __ ] on r-rated horror film big
monsters and lots all sorts of swearing
and gunfire and explosions and stuff we
wanted to kind of insulate her a little
bit from it from that and I have to give
credit to Sigourney Sigourney really
took her under her wing and they formed
this great friendship and I think that
gave her a focus of course her mom was
on the set as well but you know we did
try to really insulate her a bit from
the whole experience but I remember I
have one quick carry story that this
plagues me taunts me to this day so and
maybe you remember this there's a scene
where she's encased in the alien slime
not having this structure and she's
about to get facehugger and it took a
long time to put her into it and she had
to hold really still and there were
these fiberglass pieces and then I know
I never really trusted anybody to do the
blood right or the goo right or anything
and with all the actors you guys all
know I was always putting blood on you
and so I'm doing the slime and I'm
putting it on her face exactly she's
been in this thing for you know 20
minutes holding a position and I'm
pouring this goo all over her and this
in this little tiny very you know with a
slight English accent very quiet voice
she says you know it should be illegal
for you to be able to do this too little
kids so I'm sorry 30 years later you
know well I will tell you something from
that scene because you told me do not
move we can only like pull it apart once
don't move do not do anything to break
this and I was I was pretty scared and I
didn't get scared of all the other stuff
nothing but that I was scared of and I
was sitting there and I'm kind of bored
and I must have moved my finger and
there was a little tiny tiny piece which
no one would have even noticed that my
finger brushed against and it broke it
off and I was so scared
rishu gonna know between that and having
to wash that out and and I went back to
my hotel and we were staying at this
Holiday Inn and you guys had offered to
take us somewhere but my parent my mom
where's oh no that's fine
so here it they sent me back to my hotel
fully dressed and it was around
Christmastime the GU yeah with
everything my hair everything because it
just it took hours to literally wash
everything out normally but with that
slime it was just a nightmare
so wardrobe said to my mom you know just
bring it back and her costume no big
deal so here I am it's around
Christmastime and I've got so I've got
my costume on I've got my hair is out
like this I'm filthy all over I've got
this slime dripping down me and I've got
my winter coat on and we go in and
everyone in the that worked at the hotel
knew what I was doing it was no big deal
and but I was like oh mom I don't want
to go in there so I pulled the hood up
and I went in and they were having a
Christmas ball everyone was dressed up
in tuxedos and formal gowns and my mom
and I walked into it the elevator behind
some people who were all dressed up and
they just looked at me and they all
scooted over to the other side of the
elevator and I just was like trying to
hide because I was okay so you were a
Dickens character apparently so
permanent trauma yes
No No oh that's good
you